يبلغ انتاج روسيا من النفط حوالي 11 مليون
برميل يوميا يصدر نصفها تقريبا لتحتل
المرتبه السابعه عالميا من حيث احتياطات
النفط بنسبه 25 من المئه من الاحتياط
العالمي
انتجت روسيا العمل ماضي اكثر من 500
وعشرين مليون طن من النفط اي اكثر من
ثلاثه مليارات و600 مليون برميل ينتظر ان
ينخفض هذا الانتاج هذا العام بنسبه تتراوح
ما بين خمسه في المئه وثمانيه في المئه
وعلى الصعيد الغاز تتربع روسيا على راس
قائمه منتجه الغاز الطبيعي في العالم
وتستخرج يوميا مليارا و800 مليون متر مكعب
اما احتياطات روسيا من الغاز فتقدر باكثر
من 74 مليون متر مكعب من الموارد القابله
للاستخراج وحوالي 190 هجريون متر مكعب من
الموارد المتوقع وتلك كميه يعتق انها
ستكون كافيه ل 80 او 100 عاما من الانتاج
اليومي عام 2021 صدرت روسيا اكثر من 200
مليار متر مكعب من الغاز ذهبت اغلبيتها
الساحقه الى اوروبا ودولي اسيا الوسطى